wir ringen um reaktionen im fall wally
gibt es noch keine antwort von
bundesregierung eu oder nato der kreml
weist die verantwortung für den
giftanschlag zurück urteil nach
journalisten maut in der slowakei wird
der mutmaßliche drahtzieher ein
geschäftsmann überraschend
freigesprochen nations league auftakt in
stuttgart nach knapp zehn monaten
länderspielpause trifft deutschland am
abend auf spanien
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend seien sie
willkommen bei den zdf-nachrichten um 7
norbert lehmann ist für den sport dabei
sowohl am tor vorbei der giftanschlag
auf den kremlkritiker nav allen er hat
das verhältnis russlands zu deutschland
und dem westen überhaupt auf einen neuen
tiefpunkt befördert es scheint als sei
dieser anschlag der tropfen der das fass
zum überlaufen bringt bevor wir in
unseren reaktionen kommen einen blick
auf eine lange reihe russischer
konflikte mit dem westen vor allem die
annexion der krim 2014 sorgte weltweit
für empörung
oder die rolle russlands in syrien krieg
seit jahren stützt moskau dort den
machthaber ersatz mit waffen und
soldaten
außerdem soll russland ausländische
wahlen beeinflusst haben vor allem die
letzte us wahl bei der donald trump
gewann
und dann gibt es noch vorfälle die ganz
direkt die deutsch-russischen
beziehungen betreffen thomas garcia
es geschieht 2015 cyber angriff auf den
bundestag der größte bisher auf das
deutsche parlament rechner von
abgeordneten infiziert mit
spionage-software auch ein büro der
kanzlerin vor vier monaten
internationaler haftbefehl fahndung nach
diesem russischen hacker und immer
vehementer die frage ob nicht eher
hinter der attacke steckt russlands
präsident putin
merkel spricht von einem ungeheuerlichen
vorgang experten von zunehmender
aggressionen auch gegenüber deutschland
um zu zeigen russland ist hier ein
geopolitischer faktor der nicht
übersehen werden kann der ernst genommen
werden will der euch weh tun kann und
offensichtlich auch über leichen geht
letzteres so die vermutung passiert vor
einem jahr ein georgier wird ermordet in
berlin-tiergarten nähe regierungsviertel
behörden glauben der kreml gab den
auftrag dann der betrugsfall wirecard
schlüsselfigur jan marschalek medien
sagen er flüchtet nach moskau wird
geschützt vom geheimdienst nun der fall
navalny nach dem anschlag holte die
bundesregierung ihn nach
berlin dort der nachweis von novitec
gift zuerst entwickelt in der udssr
nicht zum ersten mal eingesetzt
anschläge affären nie beweise die zu
russlands spitze führen wie reagieren
sehr sehr klar sagen dass russland
völkerrecht bericht sei dass durch die
angriffe auf angriff auf die
souveränität anderer staaten oder
dadurch dass es verbotene waffen
einsetzt das verhältnis der kanzlerin zu
russlands präsidenten war bereits
angeknackst jetzt scheint es richtig
schwierig zu werden
russlands botschafter in deutschland
sehr gerne tasche hat heute gegenüber
dem zdf die vorwürfe im fall einer wahl
nie zurückgewiesen
bei dessen verlegung nach berlin habe
der oppositionspolitiker kein gift im
körper gehabt welche konsequenzen der
anschlag für russland haben wird ist
bisher noch offen
fdp und grüne fordern den fertigbau der
deutsch russischen pipeline nord stream
zwei zu stoppen
auch von neuen sanktionen ist die rede
andreas künast als angela merkel am
nachmittag vorm kanzleramt steht
überschlagen sich die kommentare das
ausland die eu die nato alle parteien
haben fragen merkel hat kanzler alltag
sie hat ihre antwort gegeben
die ungewöhnliche schärfe der gestern
aufgebaute druck deutschlands klare
haltung im fall navalny hat hohe
erwartungen geweckt an die regierung in
moskau und die in berlin
wir halten es mit dieser klaren haltung
nicht für vereinbar wenn beispielsweise
große infrastrukturprojekte wie die
pipeline nord stream zwei vorangetrieben
werden als wäre nichts gewesen den
fertigbau von nord stream zwei stoppen
das fordern auch grüne und große teile
der spd
merkels unionsparteien bremsen das eine
hat mit dem anderen aus unserer sicht
zunächst mal nichts zu tun auch
gleichwohl zugegebenermaßen ist dieses
projekt dann nicht mit einem positiven
licht begleiten lässt
scharf und voller gegen vorwürfe die
reaktion aus moskau sergej naryschkin
chef des auslandsgeheimdienstes swr will
nicht ausschließen dass spezialkräfte
des westens hinter der vergiftung
stecken auch russlands botschafter in
berlin sergej netschajew ist die
feststellung wichtig dass vor der
verlegung von havanna aus rumpf nach
berlin in seine proben keine spuren von
giftstoffen nachgewiesen worden war
während russland die glaubwürdigkeit des
bundeswehr labors in frage stellt
unterstützen in deutschland alle
parteien die schlussfolgerungen der
regierung bis auf die afg wir uns
gewünscht ist auch von neutraler stelle
vielleicht bestätigt wollen wir es gibt
auch labor in der schweiz um eine
neutralität auch darzustellen
der anschlag auf navalny vergiftet das
deutsch russische verhältnis giftiger
als es schon war eine angemessene
gemeinsame reaktion der eu auf den
anschlag hat kanzlerin merkel in
aussicht gestellt und da deutschland ja
gerade den vorsitz in brüssel hat könnte
sie eine solche ja nun voranbringen
warum ist das noch nicht passiert stefan
leifert weil es noch einen widerspruch
gibt zwischen der klarheit im ton und
der unklarheit darüber was daraus
eigentlich folgen soll
soll es eine gemeinsame europäische
antwort geben dann sind zwei fragen zu
beantworten zum einen die frage machen
wirklich alle mit es gibt da die
möglichen wackelkandidaten unter den 27
eu mitgliedsstaaten wie zum beispiel
ungarn griechenland oder auch italien
und das zweite ist die frage findet man
sanktionen die dem kreml auch wirklich
schaden die wirklich weh tun natürlich
träumen auch in der eu träumen auch
viele hier in brüssel
viele davon das projekt nord stream zwei
zu stoppen aber hinter vorgehaltener
hand sagen auch genau so viele dass ich
es für unrealistisch halten angesichts
des fortgeschrittenen stadiums es gilt
also sanktionen zu finden die mehr sind
als nur das einfrieren von konten oder
das ausweisen von diplomaten und diese
frage wird jetzt in den nächsten tagen
zu beantworten
der blick geht jetzt erst einmal
richtung moskau mann erwartet eine
erklärung des kreml aber das dient mehr
dem zeitgewinn wirkliche aufklärung
verspricht sich hier in brüssel niemand
davon
vielen dank stefan leifert in brüssel
wie belastet das verhältnis zwischen der
eu und russland ist zeigt sich auch in
belarus
die eu erkennt das ergebnis der
präsidentschaftswahl nicht an und plant
sanktionen gegen die regierung
lukaschenko
russland stellt ihm unterdessen
militärische hilfe in aussicht und
intensiviert die beziehung
gestern war der belarussische
außenminister in moskau
heute ist russlands regierungschef putin
in minsk christian senff berichtet wir
können uns ja so lang umarmen und küssen
wie wir wollen sagt lukaschenko zum
schutz dient und meint damit die korona
erkrankung die beide hinter sich haben
nachdem auch das foto so ist wie
lukaschenko sich das vorstellt erklärt
er seinem russischen freund erstmal was
die belarussischen geheimdienste zur
vergiftung von alex turner wollen
herausgefunden haben
ein angebliches telefonat zwischen den
nato ländern deutschland und polen
wir haben ein interessantes gespräch
abgefangen ich lasse sie es lesen wir
haben es an den fsb geschickt es beweist
eindeutig dass es eine täuschung ist es
gab keine vergiftung von navalny
lukaschenko will beeindruckend denn er
braucht den starken nachbarn die
militärische rückendeckung und er ist
abhängig von russischem öl und gas in
den letzten tagen intensivieren die
nachbarländer ihre offiziellen kontakt
wir möchten betonen dass russland die
souveränität unabhängigkeit und
territoriale integrität von belarus voll
und ganz unterstützt auf den straßen in
minsk heute deutlich weniger proteste
der besuch von moschus den interessiert
hier nur am rande
gut dass russlands ministerpräsident
belarus besucht das heißt es werden
irgendwelche aktuellen fragen gelöst
die eu sollte mit der führung in belarus
sprechen denn russland geht mit den
menschen genauso um wie die
belarussische regierung mit uns das ist
eben die sowjetische art die
abhängigkeit von russland über spielt
lukaschenko mit freundschafts gesten
demnächst will wladimir putin
in moskau empfangen nun zu einem
freispruch der viele in der slowakei
schockiert vor gericht stand ein
millionär den mafia verbindungen
nachgesagt werden
der vorwurf er soll die morde an dem
journalisten jan kulczyk und dessen
lebensgefährtin in auftrag gegeben haben
weil der informationen über ihn und
seine geschäfte gesammelt hatte
doch nach ansicht des gerichts reichten
die beweise nicht wolf christian ullrich
berichtet
vor allem die eltern hatten auf eine
verurteilung gehofft große anspannung
beim vater von jan kozak und der mutter
von martina kusnezowa
doch das urteil ist anders als von allen
erwartet der geschäftsmann marian cozma
angeklagte als drahtzieher des
doppelmordes wird überraschend
freigesprochen weil das gericht in
diesem indizienprozess selbst
unmissverständlich andeutungen in chat
nachrichten nicht als beweis gelten
liess frei gesprochen außerdem eine
mutmaßliche komplizin nur der fahrer des
mörders bekommt 25 jahre haft
es existiert kein ganz direkter beweis
aber das puzzle passt doch perfekt
zusammen
ich habe überhaupt keine zweifel dass er
mit seinen leuten dahinter steckt kozak
hatte über korruption berichtet und über
geschäfte des heute freigesprochenen
millionär scott faulkner so sieht es die
staatsanwaltschaft habe kozak ermorden
lassen um ihn zum schweigen zu bringen
der geständige mörder wurde im april zu
23 jahren haft verurteilt nach dem mord
hatte es massendemonstrationen gegeben
die slowakische regierung musste
daraufhin zurücktreten die neue
staatspräsidentin und die regierung
wollen nun herr teil die korruption
bekämpfen und präsidentin kaputt aber
glaubt dass der falkner noch nicht zu
ende ist
ich bin geschockt von diesem urteil aber
ich respektiere es und warte auf die
begründung im berufungsprozess vor dem
obersten gerichtshof wird es darum gehen
ob sich die schuld von coach beweisen
lässt
die staatsanwaltschaft hat inzwischen
berufung eingelegt der freispruch für
petzschner ist ein schwerer schlag für
die angehörigen
und er zeigt wie schwierig der kampf
gegen die korruption in der slowakei
immer noch ist auch für die justiz in
nordrhein westfalen hat sich ein
familiendrama ereignet polizisten fanden
in einer wohnung fünf tote kinder
was genau in dem mehrfamilienhaus in
solingen geschah ist noch unklar
die kinder waren ein bis acht jahre alt
die mutter gilt als wahrscheinliche
täterin sie soll anschließend versucht
haben sich umzubringen überlebte aber
schwer verletzt
im tarifstreit im baugewerbe gibt es
einen schlichterspruch die rund 850.000
beschäftigten sollen ab januar im westen
2,6 prozent mehr lohn bekommen
im osten 2,7 prozent darin enthalten ist
erstmals eine vergütung der fahrtzeiten
zur baustelle
sie soll bereits ab oktober gezahlt
werden zudem soll es eine einmalige
corona prämie von 500 euro geben
die tarifparteien haben zwei wochen zeit
über den kompromiss zu entscheiden
einen bonus für besondere leistungen in
der korona krise sollen jetzt auch
pflegekräfte in den kliniken bekommen
einmalig 1000 euro für maximal 100.000
beschäftigte
das heißt aber auch drei viertel der
pflegerinnen und pfleger gehen leer aus
denn nur mitarbeiter von kliniken mit
vielen kurven patienten erhalten den
bonus altenpflege und pflegerinnen haben
bereits eine prämie bekommen
schauen wir auf die korona zahlen in
deutschland die gemeldeten
neuinfektionen bleiben auf dem niveau
der letzten tage im durchschnitt der
vergangenen woche haben sich täglich
1200 menschen mit dem virus angesteckt
elon musk ist der popstar der modernen
industrie pionier bei der produktion von
elektroautos raketen für die raumfahrt
und manchem mehr und großinvestor in
brandenburg in grünheide entsteht sein
autowerk das projekt ist durchaus
umstritten um mitternacht endet die
einspruchsfrist
jetzt ist der tesla chef auf
deutschland-besuch jan meyer berichtet
in maskat allen grund gut gelaunt zu
sein in grünheide
denn der bau liegt im zeitplan der us
amerikanische unternehmer und visionär
gibt seinen fans autogramme
zu den kritikern des mega projekt kommt
so viel wir sind sehr offen für kritik
und ratschläge
lasst es uns einfach wissen pro jahr
sollen bis zu 500.000 elektroautos vom
band laufen etwa 12.000 beschäftigte
werden dann im drei schicht system
arbeiten eine bürgerinitiative sieht in
dem bauvorhaben das in rekordtempo
entsteht eine gefahr für die umwelt
fast 400 einwände sind bislang bei den
behörden eingegangen
das landesumweltamt sieht das autowerk
offenbar dennoch auf gutem weg mit stand
heute 14 uhr können wir keine
grundsätzlichen genehmigungs hindernisse
erkennen wir sind der auffassung dass
alle die probleme durch die durch die
einwender auf geworden sind auch lösbar
und beherrschbar sind
in zwei wochen werden die einsprüche
öffentlich erörtert erst danach wird
über die endgültige baugenehmigung
entschieden musk macht indes weiter auf
tempo zur einweihungsparty im nächsten
jahr hat er heute alle bewohner von
grünheide eingeladen
in berlin findet seit heute die
technik-messe ifa statt tatsächlich die
erste große messe seit beginn der korona
krise in den vergangenen monaten wurden
fast alle veranstaltungen abgesagt oder
verschoben
die tourismusmesse in berlin etwa die
leipziger buchmesse oder die
handwerksmesse in münchen
vergangene woche gab es videospiele auf
der gamescom rein digital jetzt also die
ifa im kleinformat und mit hygiene
konzept anzogen multimedia vorträge
statt technik zum anfassen
die ifa ist zum fachkongress geschrumpft
käufer müssen draußen bleiben geräte
sucht man meist vergeblich april zähler
verhindern dass zu viele fachbesucher
zusammen kommen nach zuletzt fast 2000
herstellern sind jetzt nur knapp 100 da
und froh dass die messe überhaupt
stattfindet selbstverständlich brauchen
wir so eine veranstaltung weil messen
haben ja die aufgabenstellung
innovations- und konsumenten zu bringen
zum handel und entsprechend auch die
medien zu begeistern
und deshalb braucht man gerade in der
jetzigen zeit eine veranstaltung wird
den ruf als weltweite leitmesse war das
berliner messegelände im letzten jahr
noch komplett ausgebucht so reicht für
die kiefer ohne publikum jetzt der platz
in gerade mal fünf fallen dabei gehört
die branche zu den corona gewinnern
erzielte im ersten halbjahr ein 20
prozent mehr umsatz bei pcs und laptops
5% plus bei der heimelektronik
das hat damit zu tun dass die
konsumenten sich zu hause ich sag mal
eingenistet haben zu hause arbeiten zu
hause kochen essen und auch zuhause sich
mehr und mehr mit elektronikprodukten
befassen und das hat zu einem
regelrechten boden geführt die
messewirtschaft rechnet dagegen
deutschlandweit nach hunderten
abgesagter schauen mit
milliarden-verlusten hofft mit der ifa
jetzt auf die trendwende
ihr ist es wichtig für uns wir sind
wieder am start und es kann losgehen
sicherlich einem kleineren format aber
es geht wieder los und von da raus gehen
wir einen schritt weiter
so denken die ifa veranstalter bereits
an die messe im nächsten jahr dann
womöglich wieder geöffnet für alle
jedes vierte kind in deutschland ist
nicht glücklich
laut einer unicef studie liegt das etwa
an fehlender unterstützung in der
familie oder an mobbing von
gleichaltrigen auch übergewicht spielt
eine rolle
durch die korona krise würden vorhandene
probleme verstärkt außerdem kämen neue
ängste hinzu am zufriedensten sind
kinder laut der studie in den
niederlanden die meisten unzufriedenen
kinder gibt es in der türkei
ja und nun zum fußball und zu dir
norbert da geht es in 90 minuten in
stuttgart los deutschland gegen spanien
ja dieser nations league kracher ist
auch der erste härtetest für die em 2000
21 bundestrainer joachim löw muss bei
der mannschaftsaufstellung improvisieren
vor allem eine
bayern stars fehlen ihm vorne wie hinten
jochen breyer in stuttgart ja was geht
gegen spanien ja das ist die große frage
die sich auch der bundestrainer selbst
stellt dieses erste geisterspiel in der
geschichte der deutschen nationalelf ist
auch für joachim löw im grunde eine
komplette wundertüte ist übrigens gerade
mit der mannschaft vor zwei minuten hier
am stadion angekommen
du hast das gesagt ohne die bayern ohne
die leipziger eine ganz neu formierte
mannschaft da haben einige die chance
sich heute aufzudrängen und die spieler
kommen auf ganz unterschiedlichen
fitnesslevel toni kroos zum beispiel den
wir gerade hier sehen kommt aus dem
urlaub andere kommen aus dem training
und keiner weiß wirklich wo er steht
umso mehr dürfen wir gespannt sein zum
beispiel auf ihn los der nach seiner
kreuzbandverletzung heute sein comeback
feiert oder auch auf robin goosens der
zum ersten mal heute im nationaltrikot
auflaufen wird deutschland gegen spanien
wir melden uns um 20.15 hier stuttgart
danke jochen breyer alle 36 vereine der
ersten und zweiten bundesliga haben
jetzt pläne zur wiederzulassung von
zuschauern in den fußballstadien
erarbeitet das gab die deutsche fußball
liga dfl heute bekannt als erster verein
hatte rb leipzig von den behörden grünes
licht bekommen
800.000 dürfen rein in leipzig die
gesundheitsbehörde bringt den gang
worauf der profifußball hoffte
unterschiedliche zuschauerzahlen in den
stadien werden akzeptiert für die ersten
paar spieltage bis zum 31.10 ist das
keine wettbewerbsverzerrung sondern das
ist ehrlich gesagt genau dass das
hantieren mit unterschiedlichen
konzepten unterschiedlichen situationen
überzeugt davon dass der belegt damit
erbracht wird das fußball corona
kompatibel gespielt werden kann mit
zuschauern und dass wir der branche im
ganzen land helfen bei union berlin
rechnet man ebenfalls zum auftakt mit
zum teil gefüllten tribünen dass wir nun
mit 5000 menschen pro spiel starten
können
das ist ein erster schritt zurück zur
normalität den gehen wir gerne und
freuen uns drauf
bundesliga start ist die zwei wochen
doch schon eine woche früher im
dfb-pokal könnten sich die stadien
langsam wieder füllen
bei den us open haben es drei deutsche
in runde drei geschafft angelique kerber
jan lennard struff und alexander zverev
allerdings tat sich die deutsche nummer
1 an
schwer gegen den jungen us
amerikanischen turnier debütanten brand
und nakashima matchball nach fast drei
stunden
wir haben uns ja gewünscht schließlich
vier sätzen und spielt morgen um den
einzug ins achtelfinale
danke und jetzt zum wetter das nach den
herbstlich anmutenden letzten tagen
morgen einen sprung zurück in den sommer
macht bis zu 30 grad erwarten uns regen
gibt es aber auch mehr dazu gleich bei
dem termin so viel von uns für heute
danke für ihr interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie heute um
halb zehn in der fußball pause und wir
sind morgen wieder für sie da um sieben
bis dahin einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine warmfront hat
uns erreichen hat heute schon einiges an
regen von westen her gebracht und das
setzt sich dann auch in der nacht weiter
vorzusehen
da kommt auch noch warme luft hinterher
und diese warme luft die spüren wir
sogar schon da kommenden nacht erst
einmal schauen wir auf das wetter unter
regnet es in der norddeutschen tiefebene
der regen zieht langsam nach osten
weiter
ansonsten ist es trocken im süden und
hier sehen sie die temperatur in der
nacht wird ziemlich mit seinem west mit
17 grad in der mitte meist um die 15
grad marke 8 grad am alpenrand
morgen im tagesverlauf gibt es weitere
schauer nördlich der mittelgebirge die
ziehen weiter nach osten ansonsten viel
sonnenschein zwischen alpenrand und
saarland und das bei temperaturen bis 30
grad am oberrhein 28 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet und 19 grad in
schleswig holstein dort wird es am
kühlsten sein
die kommenden tage bringen uns im norden
deutschlands erstmal schauer auch nach
osten sind einige dabei am samstag hier
kommt eine kaltfront auf 17 bis 27 grad
und dann ab sonntag wird es deutlich
kühler sein
zumindest spüren wir das dann deutlich
bei 15 bis 21 grad
ein schöner abend